[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s from Stanford University and welcome
everybody to our [ __ ] fixer sportcast
with my comrade Kali co-author Bob
Sutton so Bob let me kind of dive right
into it sir how did we get into this
whole [ __ ] picture how did we get it
yeah so uh
thank you
so uh we've been working on it and some
of you know this we've been working on
something we're calling the friction
project we've been working out for about
seven or eight years finally we're
getting somewhere near the end of the
book So eventually a book will appear
that might be called the friction
project but we're in the process of
brainstorming the title so I called uh
and had a conversation with somebody I
know who's really good at coming with
titles and some of you may know him the
sort of famous Guru Adam Grant so we're
doing all this brainstorming and and
Adam and I I think he came up with it
said what about calling your book the
[ __ ] fixers and we both just got so
excited and he actually still thinks the
book should be called the [ __ ] fixers
and and we read a version of The
Proposal I know with the [ __ ] fixers
immediately I remember that but but a
number of issues arose one issue was the
rose roses I don't want to have three of
my eight books have dirty titles and
another one was it wasn't a very precise
title because there are books about
friction right so it's sort of like we
took the title and put it on the shelf
right and then we're talking with Robin
and the folks at Stanford online right
and they said what should we call it
right and this is a mistake I've made in
my life before so I I think you were
involved in this too we proposed calling
it the [ __ ] fixers just so we could say
have the Stanford Administration say no
and be offended but by their lack of
Courage their lack of Daring and they
said yes so here we are so we had to do
it is that true I think that they play
backyard story I think that's a pretty
accurate recounting of water transpire
but you know uh let me begin with the
first question Bob when I think of [ __ ]
fixing for me [ __ ] is an acronym yes uh
for me [ __ ] means send help in trouble
so you know that's kind of the way I
think of uh [ __ ] and so my question is
as I and I imagine our audience also has
a similar question what exactly is the
difference between a [ __ ] fix it and a
scavenge so I mean I don't know where
you get the stuff from but anyway so so
to me a scavenger it's like a hyena like
picking through the bones
um and it's also a certain sort of
management style where uh they're making
things efficient and by eating
everything and taking it all for
themselves leaving nothing for anybody
but to me
um a [ __ ] fixer is more somebody who
cares about others and in particular
since this sort of comes out of the
friction project uh the thing that we
think about in we being you and me yeah
of course is that [ __ ] fixers they see
themselves as Trustees of other times
other's time so they don't want to waste
people's time you know one example that
we'll get to later is I'm always kind of
focused on when the administrator sends
out emails even our dear Stanford
administrators yeah every now and then
they'll send out a 1500 word email with
a 8 000 word attachment to everybody in
the university and it's like really do
we need to do that suppose you did the
math right so that would be so to me if
somebody was to Trustee of others times
they would be aware of their impact on
others and then the other part which we
should really emphasize is that as a
trustee sometimes you're going to make
things difficult and force people to
slow down and think something that
you're actually studying right now right
right right so you know you you came up
with the you know I mean you and I have
been talking about this about how [ __ ]
fixes uh Trustees of other people's time
when you were saying it one thought that
flashed through my mind was my God you
know the worst kind of power people have
over you in an organization is if they
can waste your time
I mean isn't that the world it's
absolutely you can't do anything you
have to you can't avoid the meeting you
got to be there you got to endure and
it's you know now what's interesting
about the way you describe the [ __ ]
fixers is
are they like uh concerned about the
tragedy of the commons the attentional
commons because if everybody is being
overloaded with stuff what do [ __ ]
fixers do then because of their concern
for other people's time yeah well that's
well that's one of the things that we
really think about is and to me a
broader thing and this is I wrote about
this and good boss bad boss is is what
great bosses do is they understand what
it feels like to work for them and so
part of that is wasting time and it's
also and this isn't like always being
nice like sometimes you do want to force
people to struggle I mean that's force
them to think force them to brainstorm
uh make them uncomfortable sometimes
that's necessary so I'm not saying oh
you should be nice all the time I'm
saying you should be mindful when you
make people suffer basically so the way
I'm interpreting what you're saying Bob
is hey as a trustee of time what a [ __ ]
fixer does is they make the right things
easy for you and the wrong things hard
yeah well that's the subtitle of our
books so it must be true we're not
driving people crazy thank you I was
kind of hoping that you you'd actually
sort of inject that now
you know when you when the this is a
question for you all of us uh you know
listening to our podcast and you and I
as well is when
you know let's actually look at the
content of a [ __ ] fixers work is one
part a little bit of therapy is the
other participation so so this is what
like one of our mottos of course is is
that is when it comes to [ __ ] fixer it's
it's especially in the leadership board
a lot of it's organizational design
incentives how it's structured uh
schedules and all that sort of stuff but
one thing that we know is that uh and I
always think about there's a difference
between what you do and how you do it so
part of it is therapy is is is helping
people deal with their anxiety uh
yesterday uh so Robin who is our our
host today we had a conversation with
Todd Park who's going to be joining us
Todd Park kept talking about the
importance of love I can't believe it
I'm talking about to this like severe
capitalist and he talks about love for
10 minutes I think that's it therapy in
his in his argument was that um when we
all know how bad our Pace our Health
Care system in the United States is that
if patients felt love right they would
love themselves more and they'd take
better care of themselves right and then
they take better care of others that's
right so so they'd be healthier and
actually reduce costs so he was stunking
in a sense about the contagion of love
and also the importance of self-love
because you would take better care of
yourself right so when [ __ ] fixes take
bad friction out of the organization and
when they're designing the organization
what's the orientation with which they
kind of go well I think we should talk
about the [ __ ] fixer's mindset yeah
let's do it let's move on so okay so so
Huggy so why don't you start so why is
it why is it like mowing the lawn that's
a great question Bob and if you recall
you and I learned this wonderful
metaphor of mowing the lawn from Drew
Houston yeah
and at the time when we were writing or
escaping up Excellence book and I think
this was supposed to IPO if I recall yes
we went and spoke to him and one of the
things he was saying was uh you know uh
I'm spending a lot of time in meetings
and he had a colorful term for it he
called it arm meeting yeah yeah we'll
talk about that a little bit later yeah
yeah you know and one of the things is
of course being the CEO he showed
guidelines instructing people to
self-belief themselves as to which
meetings to go to and which meetings not
to go to and I remember at the end of it
when he uh when we met him he said hey
uh after you've sent these guidelines in
the form of a memo how what was the
response and I recall him saying things
are worse than ever subtraction of bad
friction isn't like one and done it's
like
yeah and for me I find that to be a very
evocative kind of metaphor and my
question to everybody in the audience is
is there anybody mowing the lawn in your
organizations uh do people who mow the
lawn are they actually rewarded in
subsequently Bob and I were involved in
a case study and we'll actually feature
the protagonist of the case study
hopefully in another [ __ ] fixes podcast
we wrote a case study about mowing the
lawn at asteriskenica yeah so do you
want to talk a little bit
pronounce her last name for me
thank you so one of us can pronounce it
the other one can but pushkala who who
uh she she's an Indian out dealing with
her sick mother but but uh but puscalo
led a movement what's called scaling
simplification is what you call the case
that's right that uh through both top
down and bottom-up changes saved
apparently two million hours yes at this
big uh multinational company just
amazing yeah the thing that struck me
about the case and mowing the lawn was
they measured everything in terms of our
saved two million hours why do you think
they didn't actually use the metric of
dollars saved
what do you think my hypothesis is the
moment you think of Dollar Save you're
thinking of reducing costs but the
moment you're saying we're actually
reducing increa you know we're saving
time uh it's your way of telling
employees hey we recognize your lives in
the world of work you're overwhelmed
you're overworked and part of what we
want to do is we want to increase
capacity we just don't want to cram
stuff down here yeah so so one thing I
really like about that and we'll move to
the valuable prototypes in a minute one
thing I really like about about that
perspective is that I and this is one
thing we share is is we don't believe in
making everything efficient the reason
to do subtraction and to make things
easier is because there's a bunch of
things in life that are hard and slow
and should be hard and slow uh
speaking of love love is not an
efficient process those of us who've
been involved in it right Innovation and
creativity is constant failure and
confusion and dead ends
um so there's a whole bunch of things in
organizational life that should be
efficient and should be hard or they're
not done well uh so to me that's why
subtraction is important if so we can
slow down and take time to do the hard
things right and and also is you've been
talking about the danger of being
harried you don't have a bunch of
researches it's terrible it is it's a
terrible in fact I'm glad you sort of
brought that up the reason we really
need to mow the lawn and [ __ ] fixers mow
Lawns and organizations is it all goes
back to accountability people think
accountability is a word and you and I
have talked about how it's an equation
it's account multiplied by ability
accounts for us are kpis ability of
courses the skills you have and equally
importantly the time time you have to do
something now most of the time in
organizations people love the word
accountability but what I hear when they
say accountability is the account or kpi
part not the ability part and that's why
you really need to subtract and what the
research shows is when people feel that
it's time pressure and they feel things
are scarce they begin to make terrible
decisions
such as so here's a lovely experiment
that was done so they took a large group
of people randomly put them into two
groups one group was called the rich
group the other was called the poor
group and if I recall rightly the poor
group had one third the time available
to do the task or something like that
compared to the rich group but the poor
group was told hey even though you have
very little time this exercise is going
to be in five six rounds and you can
borrow time from future rounds and when
they did the experiment on getting as
many ideas as possible from people what
they found was in round one the rich
height people Rich groups who had a lot
of time and the poor groups who had very
little time they were on par in the
first round but from the second round
onwards the poor groups plummeted in
performance because they had over
borrowed from the future so they got
screwed well that's and that's what the
economy does to poor people too and
people also when you say poor one is
poverty the other is poverty of time
Poverty of resources you know all of the
above
prototypes yeah so
what's the perspective of [ __ ] fixer
brings to organization design that's
very different than a traditional well
so one thing that's really in some of
this is a growth mindset or learned
helplessness too but to me it uh the
notion that organizations are malleable
prototypes this notion that that um
while we're doing the best we can right
now but it can always change and and
where I first learned this and saw it in
action is our first guest leadership
fixers was our pal David Kelly from Ideo
it's actually way back in the 90s and
those of those of you who saw the the
first webinar with David Kelly he's got
this sort of classic Groucho March
mustaches always had it so so I was
hanging out at Ido and what happened
with idea was Ideo Grew From about 50
people in Downtown Palo Alto and they
would do a wonderful job sort of leading
a Monday morning meeting with 50 people
and in the whole and then they grew to
150 and the whole thing just got too big
and too out of control and I even
remember walking to a month Monday
morning meeting with him and he looked
at me and he said who are all these
people these people actually work for
him and this happens with an
organization scale they get to the point
right where where they're so big that
that's when you got to start putting
name tags on them because and having a
receptionist because you don't know who
the heck otherwise people just walk in
the street right right yeah and uh so
anyways so so what he did was he broke
idea into three Studios it was actually
a brilliant reorganization those of you
have been through reorganization that's
usually management says Thou shalt move
from here to there if if you don't get
fired that's like a typical
reorganization David had three people
stand up and make a pitch about why you
should join my studio and everybody got
their first choice really how cool it
was a mess I've never seen a reorg like
that but still there was anxiety about
the change right and what he did was he
shaved off his mustache which just
freaked us all out because nobody ever
seen a lot of mustache and use that to
make the point that this change in our
organizational structure is just like
the product prototypes we make we I can
grow back my mustache you can change it
and it was just David's so good at
symbolics and it was just absolutely
brilliant that's wonderful so what [ __ ]
fixers do of course is they think of an
organization as a malleable prototype
and they want the organization to be
easy to use yes can you think of
organizations that are where everything
is hard to use and where you know we
need serious [ __ ] yeah I'm thinking of
the Internal Revenue Service since I've
been wrestling with them lately if you
want an example
[Laughter]
excuse me
the Internal Revenue Service but
I really like the idea of Designing for
ease it's like a product make some
things easy make some things happen well
something should be hard like FDA
approvals should probably be hard yeah
so another thing I thought maybe we
should talk a little bit about is
you know
the great thing I realized about [ __ ]
fixers is they're very sensitive to
emotions and feelings so
you know one interesting question I have
for the audience and for all of us is
do [ __ ] fixers when they fix it and
reduce
cognitive burdens
what are they subtracting are they
merely subtracting activities or are
they also subtracting the negative
feelings Associated well that's one
thing you're really big on there's a lot
of evidence that essentially taking away
frustration and also and I I maybe I'm
early influenced because Robin and I we
just were entranced with this guy Todd
part this this notion that when people
are going through something and they
feel loved and supportive
um even if it's frustrating they feel
like they're not alone and they have
some control over the situation so so to
me that's part of the emotion because
there's some things in life that are
very difficult but if you feel that
people are on your side and the system
is out to screw you it's out to help you
right that's completely different than
if you just feel alone and and and there
and they actually don't care about you
or worse they want you to suffer right
so in listening to your bomb I mean
clearly I'm becoming much more aware of
the interdependency between
should fix this thing organizations are
malleable products and they're concerned
about removing feelings of frustration
and the like this reminds me of our
wonderful friend Michael Deering and his
conception of the leader As editoring
Leaders yeah do you want to talk a
little bit well so just Michael who uh
just is a wonderful one of the most
brilliant quirky guys if you want those
of you out there go to harrisonmetal.com
you can see some of the crazy videos he
makes but he's he's a venture capitalist
he's he's funded more than 200 amazing
amazing Harry's Razors Master Class
about he sold like wow this is kind of
interesting six companies to a Twitter
so we'll see what happens today
um so um but but Michael has this
concept that the best leaders think of
themselves as editors in Chief and
editors are very important because
they're always looking to see what to
remove what to add the order of things
so that as we read a book right or as we
watch a movie that that the experience
maintains our attention through the
process in an organizations of course is
whether or not that it's hard or easy
for us and what should be hard or easy
and when so what should fix those then
do is they're trying to take out the
things that frustrate people that
distract them that exhaust them and
maybe things that both people do yeah
yeah they take those things out or you
might bore them on purpose too
there's an argument for being boring
sometimes we could talk about that yeah
um so let's move next to uh just in the
name of time so focus on fixing things
not who to blame right so tell me about
that yeah for me the fixing things is
very connected with
things aren't activities but things are
feelings and I think one of the great
things [ __ ] fixers do is they're not in
the business of blaming individuals for
outcomes because they realize any
outcome is actually an organizational
process uh you know and so what they for
me what it reminds me of is in medical
errors the distinction between the sharp
edge and the blunt edge meaning if some
God forbid if something wrong happens in
in a hospital what do we do our first
reaction is to blame the nurse right or
the pharmacist or the doctor that's the
sharp edge they were at the point of
contact with the customer but when you
really see why an accident happened it
might well be they were actually using a
defective item and that had to do a
change with a change in purchasing
policy and that's because you're blaming
the person when it's the system yeah
exactly and what shift fixes I think are
really able to do is they realize it's
not the person it's the system and the
situation and they're always kind of
thinking about how can we reimagine
processes how can we reimagine systems
to make them both easy engaging and not
particularly he
you know put another way I think what
should fixers do is they just tell
people hey
you don't need to pay a lot of taxes
when you work you don't need to pay a
lot of emotional tax when you work we're
trying to take that emotional so yeah
yes and one thing you're implying to you
know one of my heroes Amy Edmondson at
Harvard Business School sort of the the
mother of the concept of psychological
safety I mean you talk about uh
Healthcare and where she got interested
in psychological safety was she studied
these nursing units and there'd be
nursing units that would have almost no
uh drug treatment errors reported and
then these the ones that all had really
lots of them reported and she in her
hypothesis was that when they had great
leaders they would have almost no errors
when they had bad leaders they'd have
lots of errors but she found out the
exact opposite there you go because
people when they made a mistake when
they had like the nasty mean blaming
hostile uh sort of nurse leader they
they wouldn't report there that's right
and then they couldn't learn and fix it
that's right so one of the things
therefore is ship fix is also very very
attuned to feelings of psychological
safety yes so
you know you and I have talked about
another thing what's the difference
between a poser and a doer Bob and why
do show fixers
penalize posers well this is it well
this is it's a tough thing so this goes
way back so our our sort of crazy
College colleague and friend Jeff heifer
and I wait the first business book ever
wrote was was in the well I guess the
official publication date was uh 2000
but we wrote in 1999 and uh and it was
The Knowing doing Gap and one of the
main ideas in that book was something we
called the Smart Talk trap because we
kept seeing all these organizations that
paid people to say smart things not to
actually do that and in fact Jeff who is
of course Very obnoxious he he would
make the argument that uh the whole
purpose of business school education was
to with the people in smartdown yeah
yeah oh yeah because you get paid for
how smart your comments are how smart
you're right how smart the plan so you
don't get and then you become a
consultant where you you give people
strategy and ideas and and if they don't
if it goes wrong you say well either
they didn't implement it and they were
implemented it wrong so so right but
when you sort of dig into you know real
organizational life right you have this
difference between posers and doers and
if you have only posers eventually
everything sort of goes to [ __ ] and um
to use the term and so one of our heroes
so we should have on on this uh on the
[ __ ] fixers Becky margiata yes amazing
woman so so Becky uh well she she was in
the she went to West Point she was in
the in uh in Black Ops dark Ops and all
that sort of stuff and after she
graduated or left the military she was
looking for something to do right and so
she got involved in the homelessness
movement unhoused people and so uh and
we should probably put the case up on on
the material she led something called
the hundred thousand homes Campaign
which found homes for a hundred thousand
homeless Americans and um and one thing
they figured out and working with the
different Community since it's a
decentralized movement right was that
they there were people she called Hollow
Easter Bunnies these were the people who
would come to the meetings have great
plans and and would take up all of her
staff's time and then six months later
they hadn't housed a single person and
so so what she started doing was was
distinguishing them from what she called
well censor this the chicken efforts
these were the people who actually House
people and got things done and so what
she did was she sort of got rid of the
um how Easter bunners and she would give
a little Metal Rooster as as a reward
for the people who actually got stuff
done so that's but one thing about that
story to me and is that very often the
people who are glib and are smart
talkers uh and uh as professors were
probably guilty of this in fact Jeff
pfeffer used to joke that we were giving
all these speak these speeches we were
talking about the importance of doing
but we weren't actually doing anything
so uh so I guess I'm being hypocritical
here but but we all know in
organizational life that sometimes it's
it's the it's the posers who get ahead
right and it's the doers who sort of uh
sort of get pushed to the side and don't
get any credit so this is really
interesting so in other words we could
actually go to an organization look at
the sea we look at leadership and say
hey how many how many Easter bunnies are
there as opposed to chicken effort yes
and that's like a little quick audit you
can do to get a sense of what resources
you have well so this is actually
related to let's let's talk about the
fifth one because we're almost there
directly so honest people are uh
trouble not just firefighters so you
were just talking to me uh right before
about the proactivity penalty why don't
you describe that thank you so
proactivity means who is a proactive
person somebody who anticipates the
future somebody who reimagines it plans
for the future and somebody who acts
that's what a proactive person is
and and but I was just mentioning to Bob
this idea of a proactive penalty because
organizations need a lot of proactivity
we really need to anticipate plan uh etc
for the future
but the problem is
there's a big contrast between proactive
people who anticipate plan because once
you anticipate plan for the future you
actually avoid problems you help the
organization avert problems and because
you help the organization to avoid and
avert problems people don't see the
problems people don't see what you did
because what you did was is hard to
observe and for the rest of the
organization pretty invisible and what I
mean by a proactivity penalty is those
who do that they actually get very
little records very little the people
who get recognition are firefighters the
firefighters because you can see all the
dramatic actions they're taking you know
they're taking the water the hose and
you know they're climbing up they're
putting the fire out and so in short
reacting to problems is more visible
it's emotionally arousing and therefore
who do you think is going to be receive
a lot more people so it's interesting so
we had since we had David Kelly last
time I remember having he had this
brilliant uh co-founder of IBO named
Bill Margaret but Margaret actually
invented it has the has the patent for
the modern laptop the clam shell shape
and everything and one time I was
talking to Bill and he was saying so the
best designs the best systems the best
leaders they create systems where you
notice that you don't notice nothing's
happening so so this thing where it you
know it's so easy that you don't even
realize how painless it is and and this
sort of when you build systems that if
you will have an absence of
inconvenience for other people we don't
even notice those sort of people that's
right so so I mean that's amazing so
we've got a question so this is from
Malik oh we've got some great ones here
yeah can someone younger become a [ __ ]
fixers I I think that it's young people
who fix most of this [ __ ] so I think I
just just seeing what happens it well in
every system I've ever been a part of
right uh the the senior older people
make the proclamation but the real work
both and in fact you you can you can
look at uh look at look at research on
power versus powerlessness there there's
um great research that shows that
essentially uh the people have less
power and are often younger they both do
all the actual work of the organization
and plus they do all this interpretive
work of trying to figure out when to
ignore the boss not to actually get the
right things done that's that's right
great question real quick yeah I think
um
so Dwayne let me respond and compliment
what Bob just said in the following way
can younger people become [ __ ] fixes as
Bob just said absolutely this is even
more current now because the millennial
generation they're activists they
constantly want to change things and of
course they're going to actually fix it
now you raise a very interesting issue
about how do they Voice issues and this
is where Malik what you need to think
about is are you going to present an
issue as an interpersonal problem or an
Institutional problem if you present
things as interpersonal problems that
can often be caused because there's
plenty of [ __ ] in organizations people
say the problem is between them let them
fix it but if you instead present it as
an Institutional problem there's a
better chance of like I would think of
fixing the [ __ ] uh Karen asks a
delightfully mysterious person do you
find that often times the firefighters
were also the ones who started the fire
so this is the what you do is you you
cause trouble and then you get paid to
fix it that's right so so I I I'm sure
that happens in organizations so that's
that's sort of like malicious Mischief
that's right you know and that's right
but I I really love your question Karen
and I agree with Bob that uh certainly
there are people who start fires and
then fix it because that's the way they
communicate their Mastery or a problem
to other people that's kind of what they
do uh so Richard let's let's address
Richard's question and then go into
Pride but we got a couple minutes for
that yeah please keep asking the
questions keep asking the questions your
questions aren't interruptions the gifts
to us
uh by the way that's the way [ __ ] fixers
think about things too questions aren't
prom you know hassles but they're
actually gifts so Richard has an
interesting question about you know do
[ __ ] fixers actually get persecuted by
others what should leaders do in order
for [ __ ] fixers to
I can't see the thing fully but uh I
believe it has to do with exceeding the
impact of firefighters so our [ __ ] fixes
persecuted oh yeah well sometimes they
are because people
because what they'll do is they'll ex
you talk about powerful people they'll
expose the misdeeds of powerful people
so I so this idea of sort of uh
whistleblowers and organizations and
there's a large body of research that
shows that the whistleblowers have a
difficult thing but if you actually
wanted to be a good leader let's let's
talk about what would be best practice
and there are some CEOs I know this and
this goes back in some ways to Amy
edmondson's thing in many organizations
there's people who are sort of known as
complainers and stuff like that and um
and and when I think a smart leader does
is is befriend and actually learned from
noisy complainers so there's one Co I I
won't I won't mention and what she does
is that um there's usually the person
the organization that complains and
causes the most trouble and she
describes that person as as sort of like
the early warning system uh because she
says that sort of following especially
one person in her organization this
person almost always complains before
everybody else and everybody used to
ignore and say oh like Chicken Little
right but almost always she was when
those people could connect the dots
right so so now what she does is she
glorifies right uh this noisy complainer
and and uh this is somebody actually the
board even wanted to get rid of and she
said no we have to keep her because
she's kept me under so much trouble it's
ridiculous that's a lovely example and
Richard I mean one of the things that
what leaders can do to make sure that
[ __ ] fixing is actually rewarded a
simple first step is to actually have an
upside downtown hall meeting in a
regular town hall meeting what does the
boss do the boss kind of interns and
goes on and on and on
in an upside down town hall meeting the
boss doesn't make a PowerPoint
presentation instead what happens is
people ask the boss questions and those
questions actually give you clues about
where the you know in you know where are
you know where are the orphan problems
in a company and that's what [ __ ] fixers
do too because [ __ ] fixing they take on
Orphan problems problems that fall
through the cracks between silos and
departments nobody cares that's what
they actually do so let me address a
girl's problem then let's move on to
Pride a little bit
so so so so Carol so do you see more
[ __ ] in companies with high profit
margins I would say yes but not
for sort of reverse reason is and this
happens in Silicon Valley all the time
and I you know and I I wouldn't name
companies but Google could be one
um and what happens is they get so much
money just sort of pouring in right
because they have such like a a huge
profit machine that's just cranking that
what happens is while the the workers
the people develop the product who sell
it and so forth that they don't really
grow very much but this huge
administrative apparatus grows around
them and so what happens is that the
profits are taken to grow what they call
the administrative ratio and what
happens over time and this is one of the
things that actually kills organizations
and why we don't have a lot of um
especially corporations that last more
than 100 years most when they most of
them die after 25 30 years something
like that
um is is what happens is initially
they're profitable and and then it grows
this administrative ratio higher and
higher so so Carol at least my
hypothesis and there's some evidence to
support this rated ratio and we've got
to be be careful those of us in
universities because we suffer from this
problem too is that you have this
administrative bloat that gets worse and
worse so you know Carolina's actually
chuckling when I saw your question
because yesterday I was teaching in an
executive program at Stanford and
wonderful participants came up with an
interesting example of a company that
shall be unnamed that launched an
initiative called pgp which meant profit
growth plan you know which speaks in
part to your question and profits so I
asked him uh this executive I said
that's what the senior leaders described
the plan as pgp profit growth plan how
did the rest of the employees perceive
it he laughed and said pgp for them
meant prepare to get pounded so yeah you
know and you see the problem so
what happens is in the Quest for Prophet
we don't subtract carefully and
thoughtfully instead we exhort people to
do more and we overburden them and you
kind of get into a bad kind of vicious
cycle so you have to be very careful
when you're actually having this quest
for profit without [ __ ] fixing uh let's
move on to Pride yeah because we've got
about it Erica has one quick question do
it okay yeah Erica says how can I become
someone that averts trouble and uh not
just a firefighter if most of my time is
spent on fixing ships they get so busy
putting out fires you don't have time to
to sort of fix the problem that's right
so
you know you ask a great question I
think the thing to do is
the first thing to realize is it's very
hard for you yourself by yourself to
avert trouble you need to coordinate
with people yeah you need to kind of
make sure there are no broken
connections and that there is a group of
people interested in solving or
anticipating and have orphan problem and
actually fixing that uh and the other
thing to do is you can become one you
can become a proactive individual by
taking small steps
you don't need to do everything big let
me give you an example of one
interesting thing that one company did
Borg Warner when they were developing a
big plan to scale their organization
they realize the technology of the motor
car is changing so much and it wasn't
possible just for the top management
team to keep track of it so they
appointed younger people as Trend
Champions your job is to tell us what's
going to happen to the instrument panel
in a car your job is going to tell us
what's going to happen to the driving
system in the car so by getting people
to focus on being Trend Champions they
were anticipating they were educating
the organization and they were actually
averting [ __ ] that could befall the
organization if they ignored those
Trends hopefully that helps you Erica so
think of how you can become a trend
Chancellor so let's uh so you're going
to be about seven more minutes so let's
talk a little bit about pride and um and
then we're going to have a Huggies going
to talk about his famous caring sharing
daring thing which we have a running
joke about so so just to sort of wrap up
the motivation one thing that I like to
emphasize which is the emotional part is
that is that we have we have talked um a
lot um about uh the motivation for um
for [ __ ] fixers and yes sometimes it's
financial and so and you do want to have
the right Financial incentives but
wouldn't we see organizations where it
really happens if there's some great
stream of research from Jessica Tracy on
on authentic Pride the diff so
eubaristic prize pride is where people
are proud they're narcissistic they take
credit for everything this is a real
authentic pride is essentially people
who are conscientious and caring people
who who help others succeed and and and
and and they're proud of what they've
done together and you know and going
back to our last book scaling up
Excellence one of the things that we saw
over and over again was the Hallmark of
leaders and organizations that did great
work yes yes they uh they you know
financially they were rewarded and felt
good about that but what really glued
them together was they were proud of the
things they did together and um and so
you know going back to our guest last
time David Kelly
um and this came up in the conversation
he and Steve Jobs were very close
friends
um for decades in fact they have a
patent together and the Apple three
going way back there even then and and
and one thing that uh jobs and of course
you know he was a very complicated
person and could be nasty sometimes but
one of the things that everybody I've
ever met who worked for him either at
Apple and especially at Pixar we hung
out a lot with picture especially is is
that what jobs really believed in was
Pride the notion that when you work on
something that when you look back on it
you will say you know that's I don't
know that's my Apple Mouse that's my
figure like like Sully in Monsters Inc
that was one of the teams that he said
when you look back you'll say that's my
fur uh you know moving in the wind and
looking great and everything and this
idea of a sort of authentic pride is
something that that I really think is
you know not just for [ __ ] fixing but
you look at sort of the best employees
the best organizations the ones have
great pride in that they sort of bonded
together to do something great and yes
the money might come in right but the
pride is what's the number one thing so
the emphasis is an authentic Pride
rather than hubris you were surprised
yeah by the way it's sort of sort of
like uh posers versus doers it's hard to
tell at first whether somebody's proud
because they've done something work
together or they're just an arrogant
jerk so you've got to be careful for the
initials right and that comes out of
Jessica's research too right and whom do
they give credit to and so you got like
four minutes you got to do caring
sharing daring so Robin show the slide
thank you please thank you Robin so you
know
um
when you know in the end changing
organizations requires a mindset uh
mindset is very different from culture
in for in many organization when they
say we have a culture it means they have
a list of values but in the end what you
have to do is you have to take those
values and then you've got to translate
them into a mindset and the mindset of
course means a way of thinking and a way
of doing and
you know Bob and I have had this you
know uh discussion over a couple of
years my own view is that the three core
muscles that underpin the mindset of any
company are caring sharing and daring
you have to anything that you do in the
organization employees should know the
answers to the following questions
whom should I care about how
what should I share when with whom is it
ideas Authority resources people
whatever and the third question is dairy
daring means how do you want me to take
initiative you know what constitutes
acceptable initiative now when you're a
startup all three muscles fire in unison
but as you become larger the muscle that
atrophies the fastest is the daring
muscle that's why we say oh my God a
large corporation you really need the
soul of a startup and then you put in
incentives for people to DARE but really
if you look into it more sometimes the
daring muscle weakens because the
sharing muscle is defunct and the
sharing muscle is defunct because you
don't care about yourself you'll never
tell them about your mistakes and why
you failed you only want to advertise
your successes leading to very biased
search and in turn you don't share with
your colleagues because you stop caring
for them you think they are the enemy or
they're somebody kind of out there so
all the time part of what all of you
need to be thinking about as you lead
your teams is ask yourself a simple
question at the end of the day as a
leader of my team what did I do to
improve the sense and the feeling of
caring a sense of sharing and a sense of
dairy those are the three things you
constantly need to stoke in terms of
emotions when you feel cared for and
you're sharing things feelings of
psychological safety increase you can
dare easier so uh
um that was kind of what I wanted to
share about caring sharing and daring we
have two other questions do you think we
got well you got one minute okay take
whichever you want uh um so Eduardo asks
an interesting question to be a fixer
what's the most critical Behavior what's
your take on that well so I I'm not like
the most critical Behavior sort of
person I always worry when somebody says
they have like the one Magic Bullet I
start I start uh getting nervous uh some
of the things that come to mind to me
immediately your daring thing that's
sort of a good sign like what happens
when people make mistakes it's no
accident that uh Amy Edmondson she did
psychological safety now she's writing a
book on on intelligent failure right so
what so what happens with intelligence
in Failure I think is is one side Pride
what would be some of the things would
be sort of at the top of your list so
for me the top of the list is
if you really want to be a [ __ ] fixer
you got to have a nose for Orphan
problems okay no that's that's bad you
know because you gotta actually have a
nose for where the orphan problem is
that's where you begin
so I like that an orphan problem and
then and I think it's time to and also
um the ability sort of form a posse to
tackle it that's right and I think we're
a transition we're in transition okay
so so Huggy we're gonna get rid of you
Robin help us yes please yes we're here
so everyone
um Huggies gotta go he's gotta go fix
some [ __ ] so that's right he does that's
right he's gonna leave us a little bit
early bye Huggy so so Rebecca is really
an interesting person she's somebody
that hugging and I've been working
working with for about a decade I first
met her when she was a master's student
at Stanford
um and um she went on to work at Dropbox
but but we started this friction project
seven or eight years ago and actually
Rebecca and I
um and huggie even working together on
the friction project since the beginning
um then um she became a PhD student at
Stanford she actually just defended her
thesis last week I was on her
dissertation committee and but the thing
that um Rebecca is doing now which was
actually just announced officially today
although she's been working at Asana for
a while so she's ahead of the brand new
work Innovation lab uh by Asana and uh
so one of the first projects by the lab
which I've been lucky to help Rebecca a
little bit frankly she's done most of
the work is around fixing meetings so
that's the tool that we're going to talk
about today so let's let's have the next
slide here and let me talk about this
meeting and Robin I think you can send
them the link to this Playbook so
essentially Rebecca and I um and Huggy 2
have a long-term interest in broken
meetings and organizations and in fact
Huggy mentioned an early piece that we
uh Rebecca and I wrote for Inc a
magazine in 2015 and this was our
meeting getting it Dropbox and it was
sort of amazing what uh what they did at
Dropbox this was back in 2013.
was that um they went into all the
employees calendars and they removed all
standing meetings for two weeks and made
it impossible to add meetings back in
um and it was really kind of cool
um and as a story and it certainly um
reduced the number of unnecessary
meetings for a while because people had
to pause and put them back in but as
Huggy said just about 45 minutes ago the
problem with it is in Drew Houston's
words he's the CEO was it's like mowing
a lawn one and done isn't enough okay so
sort of fast forward to this year
um 2022 so Rebecca is working at Asana
and uh and she remembers since she the
first author of this of this piece about
our meeting getting and so she starts
something that she calls meeting
doomsday with a with a small group um at
Asana marketing just nine people and
what she has them do and their volume
volunteers is uh that they went into
their calendars and for 48 hours they
removed all small standing meetings so
five or fewer people and then the idea
was they kind of stopped and they sort
of thought about the meetings and then
and then we're back in her team they
calculated how much time people saved it
was just sort of amazing it was 11 hours
per month just just like think about
that's a lot of time and there's just
one woman she's the star of this
Francesca who works in London so she
saved 32 hours a month so and this is
just by sort of pausing to think okay so
moving ahead so um what um what Rebecca
LED next was something that you called
meeting reset and this was for a larger
group and what she did was uh she she
had like 60 people and some of them did
sort of the heavy version this was where
they actually removed all standing
meetings just like um in in doomsday she
called it full doomsday and they
remember move the standing meetings for
48 hours and and they assessed actually
there's a little bit more rigor in this
one uh and I was involved in this a
little bit is what we had him do is
assess both the value of the meeting on
a three-point scale each each meeting
that they'd removed and also
um how um how much work or how much
trouble it was and then they made
decisions about removing meetings and
and and on average you can see that
people in the full participation group
saved about five hours and the people in
the light about three hours so sort of
moving ahead
um let's so let's have the next slide
let's talk a little bit about the
results and this is from the meeting
Playbook and so I'm not going to read
all of the details but you can see and
this is just an incredible number to me
that um and this isn't like a
well-managed group 48 of meetings were
not considered high value why the people
once they assess them and you can see
the 265 hours saved per month the next
one is really important from a matter of
redesign in something that we're really
thinking about a lot now which is that
70 percent of the time savings came from
not getting rid of meetings but from
redesigning meetings so for example
making a 30-minute meetings 25 minutes
one thing that I would suggest that you
might try doing and there's some
companies I work where they do this is
see if you in your team can change say
30-minute meetings to a default 25
minute meetings or 60 minutes to a
default 10-minute meetings there's
actually some pretty good research that
when you do that
um that your your level of Engagement
and and uh and and your is higher in
your level of stress is lower in the
next meeting so that's one of the kind
of things they did and then the other
thing which which you know the I the old
notion of that was a meeting that could
have been an email is that they also
would add an asynchronous component so
just for example people and and I'm not
sure this happened at Asana but it
happened in other companies I work with
where what they'll do is they'll they'll
change the Rhythm to say well we'll meet
every two weeks but we'll have an email
update every week so and oh and and then
the other thing is is that uh we were
working with this great Stanford
undergraduate Stephen Lai who did a
Model to sort of figure out what the
most valuable and least valuable
meetings were and one of the Hallmarks
and this is just so obvious it's
ridiculous
um but but a lot of this stuff is just
common sense is is that the meetings
that didn't have an agenda
um or didn't have a clear name or
purpose those were the ones that tended
to be least value and and that that old
notion that I'm not going to go to a
meeting unless there's an agenda there's
some evidence to support it here so
that's sort of the results so right now
so Robin I think you've shared the um
the URLs for this you can go in and
let's see what the next oh there we are
so so this just went live this morning I
think you're the first group to hear
about it Rebecca and I have a Harvard
Business review article that I think is
coming out tomorrow that talks about
some of this stuff but you can go and
see the work Innovation you can see the
Playbook and you can also learn about
the work Innovation lab and it's got a
lot of details of how to actually
implement this
okay so I've got about three or four
minutes left and let's look at some of
these these questions
okay so
um I so Robin I can't quite let's let's
read the next one
um so why is being a [ __ ] fixer
considered to bring more troubles is it
about mindset is it about culture
um
well that's an interesting an
interesting point in in what I would
sort of think about in that situation is
that well there's some bosses and some
hierarchies where you're just supposed
to act as if everything is good and
perfect and you just tell everybody how
wonderful things are all the time
but when you look at what it takes to
actually run an organization and to make
a great
um there's a saying and there's very
evidence-based saying that bad is
stronger than good
so there's all sort of research that I'm
just for example in in long-term marital
relationships that um that that um for
every um good interaction that uh that
that say a couple has
um I mean for every bad interaction they
have if they don't make it up with at
least five good ones things don't last
and in groups if you've got one jerk or
you've got one deadbeat performance goes
down 30 or 40 percent and and when I I
think about some of the great leaders
Alan Mullally at Ford Carlos britos and
inbev if you talk to them about the way
they actually run their organizations
they will um really when they meet with
senior leaders yes we're glad things are
going well but what they want to hear
about are the things that are wrong and
they need to fix and and this is very
consistent with the sort of old Toyota
production system the lean system that
what we're focusing on is continuous
Improvement in continuous Improvement
means well we're always fixing stuff
that's wrong or is about ready to go
wrong so to me that's sort of the [ __ ]
fixers kind of mindset
um so um
do we have any more questions I so Robin
I think that we're pretty much at the
end so um just to sort of look ahead so
um so take a look at at the new playbook
from Asana it's brand new and I would
love to hear your feedback and and
that's sort of a method that we'll all
be able to use I've got to sort of look
at my calendar and I'm going to go in
and try to see if I can make all of my
meetings shorter at the very least and
maybe get rid of a few of them and and
then the other thing sort of looking
ahead uh we'll have Todd park at the
beginning of the year next year and
we've got a bunch of interesting things
that we're sort of cooking so look for
announcements from us